uh let me ask the most important
question you guys are from
portugal both yeah uh so
who is the greatest soccer player
footballer of all time
yeah i think we're a little bit biased
on this topic but uh
i mean maradona i i
have a huge i have a you know tremendous
respect for for
what uh here we go this is the political
issue
we can convince you i i i mean i have
tremendous respect for what ronaldo has
achieved in his career and and i think
soccer is one of those sports
where i think you can get to maybe be
one of the best players in the world
we if you just have like natural talent
and even if you don't put a lot of hard
work and discipline
into soccer you can be one of the best
players in the world
and i think ronaldo is kind of like of
course he's naturally talented but yeah
the the football from exactly from
portugal um and and
not uh not the brazilian in this case
and so um
and ronaldo put like came from nothing
he is known from
being probably one of the hardest
working athletes in the game
and and i see that sometimes a lot of
these discussions about the best player
a lot of people train tend to gravitate
towards like
um you know this person is naturally
talented and the other person has to
work hard
and so and so as if it was bad
if he had to work hard to to be good at
something and i think that you know the
the
i think so many people fall into that
trap
and the reason why so many people fall
into that trap is because
if you are saying that someone is good
and achieved a lot of success by working
hard as opposed to achieving success
because it has some sort of god-given
natural talent that you can't explain
why the person was born with that
what does it tell you about you it tells
you that maybe if you work hard on a lot
of fields you could have
could accomplish a lot of great things
and i think that's hard to digest for a
lot of people
and and that way ronaldo's inspiring
that i think so you find hard work
inspiring but he's he's way too
good-looking
you know that's the yeah i don't like
him probably no i like the part of the
hard work and like
of him being like one of the hardest
working athletes in in soccer
so he is to you the greatest of all time
is he up there is is he
would be number okay do you agree with
this thing
oh hardly disagree well i definitely
disagree i mean
i i like him very much he works hard i
admire
i admire you know um would
like he's an incredible uh a goal scorer
right um but i
so first of all leo messi and there was
some confusion because i've kept saying
maradona is my favorite player but i
i think i think leo has surpassed them
so uh um it's messy
then mardona then pele for me but
the the reason is is um
there's certain aesthetic definitions of
beauty that i
admire whether it came by hard work or
through god-given talent or through
anything and it doesn't it doesn't
really matter to me there's certain
aesthetic
like genius when i when i see it to me
and uh especially it doesn't have to be
consistent it is in the case of messi
in the case of the ronaldo but just even
moments of genius
which is where maradona really shines it
i
even if that doesn't translate into like
results and goals being scored right
right and that's the challenge like they
did that
uh because that's where
people that tell me that leo messi's
never
even on strong teams have led his the
national team people as part of the
world cup
right that's really important and to me
no it's the moment like winning to me
was never important
what's more important is the moments of
genius and
but you're you're talking to the human
story
and um yeah cristiano ronaldo definitely
has a beautiful human story yeah and i
think you can't
i for me it's hard to decouple those two
um
i i don't i don't just look at you know
the the list of achievements
but i like how he got there and how he
keeps pushing the boundaries at like
almost 40.
yeah and how that sets up an example
like maybe 10 years ago i wouldn't have
ever imagined that like one of the top
players in the world could be a top
player at like 37 or
but so and there's an interesting ten
the human story is really important but
like
if you look at ronaldo he's like
he's somebody like kids could aspire to
be but at the same time i also like
maradona
who like is a as a tragic figure in many
ways
like the you know the drugs the the
temper all of those things that's
beautiful too like i don't
necessarily think to me the flaws
are beautiful too in in athletes i don't
think
you need to be perfect i agree uh from a
personality perspective those flaws
are also beautiful so but yeah there is
something about
hard work and there's also something
about the
being an underdog and being able to
carry a team
uh that's that's an argument from
maradona i don't know if you can make
that
argument for messi and ronaldo either
because they've all
played on superstar teams for most of
their lives
um so i don't know how
it you know it's it's difficult to know
how they would do
um when they had to work like did what
uh maradona had to do
to carry a team on his shoulders true
and pele did as well
and so depending on the the context yeah
maybe you could argue that with the
portuguese national team but they were
we have a good team
uh yeah but maybe with what maradona did
with you know
naples and and a couple other teams it's
it seemed
incredible this is the beauty of the
game that you know we're talking about
all these different players that have or
especially you know if you're comparing
messi and ronaldo that have such
different you know styles of play and
also even
their bodies are so different and and
and but
these two very different players can be
at the top of
the game and that's not that's the
they're not a lot of other sports
where you where you have that you know
like you have kind of a mental image of
a
basketball player and like the the top
basketball players kind of fit that
mental image and and they look a certain
way
and um but for soccer there's so there's
it's it's not so much like that and and
that's i think that's that's beautiful
uh but that's that really adds something
to the sport
well i do do you play soccer yourself
have you played that in your life what
do you find beautiful about the game
yeah i mean it's one of the i'd say it's
the biggest sport
in portugal and so growing up we played
a lot did you see the paper from
deepmind i didn't look at it
where they're like uh doing some uh
analysis
on soccer strategy interesting i said i
saved that paper
uh i haven't read it yet um it's
actually i
i when i was in college i actually did
some
research on on applying um
machine learning and statistics in
sports and in our
in our case we're doing it for
basketball
um but uh well what they're effectively
trying to do was
uh have you ever watched moneyball like
yeah so they're trying to do something
similar
right taking that in this case
basketball taking a statistical approach
to
to to basketball um the interesting
thing there is that
baseball is much more about having these
discrete events that happen kind of in
similar conditions and so it's easier to
take a statistical approach to it
whereas basketball is a much more
dynamic game it started to measure
um it started to to replicate these
conditions
and so you you have to think about it in
a slightly different way
and so we were doing work on that and
working like with the celtics to analyze
the the the data that they had like they
had these cameras in the in the arena
they were tracking the players and so
you
so they have they had a ton of data but
they didn't really know what to do with
it
and so we were doing work on that and
and
and soccer is maybe an even a step
further it's it's
right it's a game where you don't have
as many in in basketball you have
a lot of field goals and so you can
measure success uh
soccer it's it's right it's more of a
poisson process almost where
it's like you have a goal like or two
and again
in terms of metrics i wonder if there's
a way and i've actually have thought
about this in the past
never coming up with any good solution
if there's a way to definitively say
whether it's messier and now they're the
greatest of all time like
like honestly sort of measure
interesting like convert the game of
soccer into metrics like you said
baseball but like those moments of
genius like pat
like um you know if it's just about
goals or passes that led to goals
yeah that feels like it doesn't capture
the genius of the
yeah they'll be like you know like
like you kind of do you have more
metrics for instance in chess
right and you can try to understand how
hard of a move
there was you know there's like bobby
fischer has this move that like
that it's i think it's called the move
of the century where
uh you have to go so deep into the tree
to understand that that was the right
move and you can quantify
how hard it was so it'd be interesting
to try to think of those type of metrics
but say yeah for soccer
computer vision unlocks some of that for
us that's that's one possibility
i have a cool idea a computer region
product likes that you could build for
soccer let's go
i'm taking notes if you could detect the
ball
and like imagine that um this seems like
totally doable right now but like if you
could detect when the ball enters one of
the goals
and like just had like um you know a
crowd cheering for you when you're
playing soccer
with your friends every time you score a
goal or you had like the
the champions league song going on yeah
and like having that like you go
play soccer with your friends you just
turn that on and there's like a computer
vision like program analyzes the ball
detects the ball every time there's a
goal like if you miss like there's a
you know the fans are reacting to that
and then it should be pretty simple by
now
it's like i think there's an opportunity
there yeah just throwing that
i'm gonna go all out but by the way i
did uh i've never
released i was thinking of just putting
on github but i did write exactly that
which is the trackers for the players
uh for the for the bodies of the player
is this is the hard part actually
the detection of player bodies and the
ball is not hard what's hard is
very like robust tracking through time
of each of those
so like so i wrote a track of this
pretty damn good
this is this is that is that open source
i know i've never released it because
it's interesting because i thought like
i need to i would this is the perfection
thing because i knew it was going to be
like
it's going to pull me in and and it
wasn't really that done
and so i've never actually been part of
a github project where it's like really
active development
and i didn't want to make it i knew
there's a non-zero probability that will
become my life for like a half a year
that's uh because just how much i love
soccer and all those kinds of things and
and ultimately it will be all for just
the the joy
of analyzing the game which i'm all for
i remember you also like
in one of the episodes you mentioned
that you did also a lot of eye tracking
analysis
like joe rogan's that was the that was
the research side of my life
interesting yeah and you have that
library right you you kind of downloaded
all the episodes yep
allegedly and of course i didn't if
you're a lawyer listening to this no it
is
i i was listening to the episode where
you mentioned that and i was actually
there was something that i and i might
ask you for for access to that
to allegedly that library uh but i was
doing some not not regarding like eye
tracking but i was
playing around with um analyzing the
distribution of silences
on uh one of the joe rogan episodes so
like i did that for the elon
uh conversation where it's like you just
take all the silences
like after joe asked the question and
elon responded and you plot that
distribution
and like and see how how that looks like
yeah i think there's a huge opportunity
especially long-form podcasts
to do that kind of analysis bigger than
joe exactly but
it has to be a fairly unedited podcast
so that you don't cut the silence so one
of the benefits i have
like doing this podcast is like the the
what we're recording today is there's
individual audio being recorded
like i have the raw information no it's
when it's published it's all combined
together
and individual video feeds so even when
you're listening
which i usually do i only show one video
stream
i i'll know i can i can track your
blinks and so on
um but yeah but ultimately the hope is
you don't need that raw data because if
you don't need the raw data for whatever
analysis you're doing
you can then do a huge number of because
there's so
it's quickly growing now the number
especially comedians
there's uh quite a few comedians with
with long-form podcasts
and they have a lot of facial
expressions they have a lot of fun and
all those kinds of things and
it's it's prone for analysis and it's
there's so many
interesting things that that idea
actually sparked because i was watching
a
um a q a by by steve jobs and
i think was at mit and then like people
like did
a talk there and then the q and a
started and people started asking
questions that
i was i was working while listening to
it and like someone asked the question
and he goes like on a 20-second silence
before answering the question i
like i had to check if the if the video
hadn't paused or something
and and i was thinking about like like
if that is a feature of a person like
how long on average you take
to respond to a question and if it's
like that's fascinating it has to do
with it like how thoughtful you are and
if that changes over time
but it also could be this really
fascinating metric because it also could
be
it's certainly a feature of a person but
it's also a function of the question
like if you normalize to the person you
can probably infer a bunch of stuff
about the question
so it's a nice flag like it's a really
strong signal
the length of that silence relative to
the usual silence they have
so one the silence is a measure of how
thoughtful they are
and two the particular sounds doesn't
measure how
thoughtful the question was thoughtful
the question was it's really interesting
i mean
yeah i just analyzed elon's uh
um episode but i think there's like room
for
exploration there i feel like the
average they could do for comedians
would be
like i mean the time would be so small
because you're trained to like i would
think you're reacting to hecklers you're
reacting to all sorts of things you have
to be like so quick maybe
right yeah but some of the greatest
comedians are very good at sitting in
the silence
i mean there there's louis ck they play
with that
because you have a rhythm and you like
um
dave chappelle a comedian who did uh
joe's show recently
he has uh especially when he's just
having a conversation
he does long pauses it's kind of cool
because it uh
it's one of the ways to have people hang
in your word
is to play with the pauses to play with
the silences
and the emphasis and like mid-sentence
there's a bunch of different things that
uh
it'd be interesting to really really
analyze but still soccer to me is uh
that's that that one fascinating just i
just want a conclusive
definitive statement about it's like
there are so many
soccer highlights of both messi and
ronaldo
i just feel like the raw data is there
um because you don't have that with pele
mardonna yeah
just through yeah through but here's a
huge amount of high def data
then the the annoying the difficult
thing and this is really hard for
tracking
and this is actually where i kind of
gave up because i didn't really give
much effort but i gave up
to the the way that highlights or
usually
football match are filmed is they switch
the camera
so they'll they'll do a different switch
perspective so you have to
it's a really interesting computer
vision problem when the perspective is
switched you still have a lot of overlap
about the players but the perspective is
sufficiently different that you have to
like
recompute everything so i there there's
two ways to solve this so one
is doing it the full way where you're
constantly doing the slam problem
you're doing a 3d reconstruction the
whole time and projecting into that 3d
world
but you could also there could be some
hex that i wonder
like some trick where you can hop like
when the perspective shifts do a high
probability
tracking hops from one object to another
but
i i thought especially in exciting
moments when
when uh when you're passing players
like you're doing a single ball dribble
across players and you switch
perspective which is when they often do
when you're making a run on goal
if you switch your perspective it's it
feels like that's going to be really
tricky to get right
automatically but in that case i feel
like if somebody released that data set
or it's like you just have all like
these
this data set a massive data set of all
these games from
from say ronaldo and messi like and just
you just add that in like
whatever csv format and some some
publicly available data set like that
i feel like people would just there
there would be so many cool things that
you could do with it and you just set it
free and then like the
world would like do its thing and then
like interesting things would come out
of it
by the way i have this data set so
the two things that i've did of this
scale uh
is soccer so it's body pose and ball
tracking for soccer
and then um i try it's pupil tracking
and blink tracking
for it was joe rogan and a few other
podcasts that i did
so those are the two data sets i have
did you analyze any of your podcasts
no i i think i really started doing this
podcast
after after doing that work and it's
difficult
to maybe i'd be afraid of what i find
i'm already annoyed with my own voice
and video like editing it
uh but perhaps that's the honest thing
to do because uh one useful thing
about doing computer vision about myself
is like
i know what i was thinking at the time
so you can start to like
connect the particular the behavioral
peculiarities
of like the way you blink the way you
squint the way you
close your eyes like talking about
details
there's it's like for example i just
closed my eyes
is that a blink or no like
figuring that out in terms of timing in
terms of the blink dynamics
is tricky it's very doable i i think
there's
universal laws about what is a blink and
what is a closed eye
and all those things plus makeup and
eyelashes i actually um
have annoyingly long eyelashes so i
remember when i was doing a lot of this
work i
i would cut off my eyelashes
when like what especially it was funny
like female colleagues were like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
like those no keep the eyelashes but
because it got in the way made the
computer vision a lot more
difficult but super interesting topics
yeah but speaking about the one uh still
on the topic of the
data sets for sports there's one um one
paper that and i actually annotated it
on vermont
and uh it's it was published in
uh 90s 90s i believe 90s or 80s i forget
but
they're you the researcher was
effectively looking
at the hot and phenomena
in basketball right so whether like the
fact that you just
made a field goal um if you know if on
your next attempt
if you're more likely to make it or not
um
and it was super interesting because i
mean he pulled like i think 100
undergrads and
i think from stanford and cornell and
asking people like do you
you think that's that you have a higher
likelihood of making your
free throw if you just just made one and
i think it's like 68
68 said yes they believe that
and then he looked at the data
and this was back in as i said like a
few decades ago and so
i think he had a data set of about he
looked at it specifically for free
throws
and he had a data set of about five
thousand free throws
and um and effectively what he found
was that specifically in the case of
free throws
he didn't for the aggregate data he
didn't find
um that he couldn't really spot that
correlation that hot and correlation so
if you made the first one
you weren't more likely to to make the
second one what he did find
was that they were just better at the
second one because you just got like
maybe a tiny practice and you just
you attempted once and then and then
you're going to be better at the next
one
and then i i then i went and there's a
data set on kaggle
that has like 600 000 free throws
and i reran the the same computations
and
and and confirmed like you can see a
very clear pattern
that they're just better at their second
free throw
that's interesting because i think
they're similar that kind of analysis is
so awesome
because i think with tennis they have
like uh like a fault like
when you serve they have analysis of
like are you most
likely to miss the second serve if you
missed first obviously
um yeah i think that's the case so that
integrates
that's so cool when psychology is
converted into metrics in that way and
in sports
it's especially cool because it's such a
constrained system
that you can really study human
psychology because it's repeated
it's constrained so many things are
controlled which is something you rarely
have
in in the wild psychological experiments
so it's cool
uh plus everyone loves it like sports is
really cool to analyze
people actually care about the results
yeah um i still think well like i
yeah and i will definitely publish uh
this work on messi versus ronaldo and
i'd love to read it objective fully
objective to peer review
uh yeah this is very true this is not
past peer review
you